started
[Music]
and we have to start
and
here we go
all right ladies and
gentlemen surprise monday version of the
podcast you know you know the name
[Music]
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome back to riffing
with griffin
back on a monday only because i'm
leaving for my honeymoon and oh what
happened oh man oh
and um
i got to get this in cause i'm gonna be
busy tomorrow doing honeymoon stuff
so on the podcast today i'm gonna have
rachel pop on mrs griffin griffin with
mrs griffin
and um you know we're gonna see how it
goes i'm gonna talk about the amber herd
johnny depp finally give you my thoughts
give me my thoughts on golden state
warriors and then i'm off to the airport
so once again enjoy
all right riffing with griffin
let me get this right mike ready because
she's gonna have to use that mic cause i
have a whole technical difficulties
going on but anyways guys welcome back
to riffing with griffin but before we
get started let's pay some bills first
up
guys
upstart
upstart.com upstart has helped over 1.8
million customers on their path to
financial freedom don't wait check your
rate today at upstart.com
griffin loan amounts may vary go to
upstart.com
griffin
and also
five
cbd thanks to our new sponsor 5cbd they
make full spectrum cbd and thc products
that you can
really feel go to 5cbd.com
griffin and enter code griffin at
checkout for 30 off and free shipping on
your first
order
boom
taking care of business paying them
bills
paying in pre-roll bills um what's up
everybody um how you doing uh let's see
what is going on this week uh
you know
had a good time this week i went to my
buddy crystalia's wedding
and i got to tell you it was really good
so i've had like two weeks of love like
two weeks of love which is uh great
you know
and i'm gonna have mrs griffin come on
the podcast maybe i should just get her
now ray chow
[Laughter]
i don't know where she is maybe she'll
uh
she's gonna pop in i'm gonna have her
pop in and sit down and we'll uh
talk to her but it was really fun uh we
had a really good time you know i'm
gonna go to my instagram if you go to my
instagram
you can see a bunch of the pictures
rach where are you
um
oh that's not it
what
you're doing your hair oh my god why are
you of course you dressed up
uh yeah but i'll just show you guys some
of the pictures
if you go to my instagram you can see a
bunch of pictures that's me and
dalia's dad uh bill delia such a good
dude this is like some some people that
are at the wedding
craig conant really funny comic and his
lady sadie uh funny there's rick of
course rick glassman was there schaub
was there and then there's rachel and i
you know doing our rachel and i stuff
um and then let's see
there's a great picture of us there
uh oh here's some pictures i know some
other pictures it was actually a really
beautiful wedding in santa barbara great
setting
uh it was you know bobby was there we
just took it was it was a fun time with
a bunch of fun people so we had a good
time and of course uh can we talk about
how bobby lee dressed up for this
wedding
you know
how's bobby gonna dress up for this
wedding
and not for
you know but i think he got
rachel grab this
be careful careful careful i i think
because he got a lot of slack he got a
lot of don't turn it on yet he got a lot
of nonsense for uh
not dressing up
at
at our wedding wearing a beanie and he
told me so when i first saw him i was
like what are you doing man how you
dressed up like this and he was like man
i got so much flack for wearing the
beanie he was like so he like borrowed
the jacket and it was like the jacket
was it didn't even fit properly he had
to like turn it in and do kinds of stuff
uh you know so it was great but anyways
you know what now that i got her here
right now ladies and gentlemen for the
first time on the podcast
welcome to riffin with griffin riffin
with
mrs griffin mrs rachel griffin hey babe
how you
doing it's so good to be back did you
turn it on turn on the mic babe turn on
the bike
did you turn it on hello there you go
now i'll say something thanks for having
me
[Laughter]
why you being all professional
thanks for having me well
you know you kept saying it's live babe
i know i'm professional yeah you are
professional so we're live with rachel
right now guys if you have any questions
in the chat now's the time so we're
going on our honeymoon we're going to
cancun i can't wait we're leaving from
uh we're leaving from here and rachel's
packing she's a great packer but i just
i have some questions for you so rachel
when you why do you have to try on every
outfit you before you pack it in the
suitcase tell us please i like to
come to the vacation prepared so i don't
have to think about what i'm gonna wear
there so then i just look at my phone
look at the photos and i'm basically
i know exactly what i'm going to wear
each day and then your outfit matches my
outfit yeah so rachel takes now it's
like photo coordinated
and
move the mic up more babe
so basically
it's just all in photos and i could tell
you what outfits for what day and it's
just to stay organized and to stay on
track of like what outfits you've worn
and what outfits you have
to make sure that everything you bring
to vacation you bring back yeah always
really yeah yeah see she's like so good
at packing and all that kind of stuff
but it takes forever she's in there like
she was in there for like six hours last
night getting everything together
because that's how uh because i wanted
to bring the
least amount as possible as well so i
was like trying to like narrow my shoes
selection down to like
like night shoes and then days you know
sandals and then
the purse that matches the sandals and
then the person matches the heels and
you know
it's just
i mean you match everything you have so
many swim outfits
oh really i'm so excited to see you in
everyone look out
like i didn't even pack she packed for
me so all the things she had i didn't
really want a pack for you
baby we're live don't don't say mean
things about me please i'm not saying
mean things thank you thank you thank
you you told me to pack for you so i
packed for you i told you to pack for me
so you just go you just go put me on
blast live you know what i mean all
right but okay so for having me and the
wedding was amazing
better than i could dream are you
talking about our wedding yeah all right
we're talking about wedding are you
talking about talk about our wedding
tell us tell us what because i you
weren't on last week because i couldn't
get this thing to work properly and this
is even still i'm still like not
don't like it but we're doing it so tell
us tell everybody what you think of our
wedding babe okay well
you know it was 10 days away or 10 days
what is it 10 days
ago it was 10 days ago uh-huh
and
okay so let me see if i even remember
because like you know when you get so
excited you just black out everything
that day yeah that's kind of what
happened
it is
well
i mean i remember
parts of it
i mean i remember the whole night i
obviously was sober and didn't drink or
whatever but
it was
it was just like the excitement of like
getting the vows
you know
done and walking down the aisle and
everyone you know like just staring and
it's just a lot of attention
and i wasn't
you know i didn't know how really to
react so i was just like a lot of the
times like in awe of like what was
happening okay let's talk about this
you know i had talked about it on my
last episode but you know like two days
before the wedding
you know you were in there looking at
your dress and you were just like in
tears like you didn't you were just like
okay well i mean shout out to michael
costello he made an amazing gown that i
love
and
it was such a beautiful
um experience um
making a custom dress but like i've
yeah i melted down um yeah you did you
melt it down it's a good way to say it
and um
like when you
when you make a dress
and then you go to a fitting
things change every fitting and then
the dress that i ended up with
um at the end i was like still a little
unsure if it was like
that's
what i exp or like had envisioned in my
head
and so
i'm showing it right now babe so
okay well
i mean it's also on my instagram the
whole story i'm on your i'm on your
instagram right now so they can see like
before all the rhinestones oh you did
you put that oh that's right okay so if
you guys can see like right here there's
like a where the different sizes okay
i'm telling them so like right there in
the middle part right there there's like
the rhinestone part it wasn't like that
the day before the wedding and then like
she didn't have a neck this necklace
that she was gonna have on it wasn't
there before the wedding okay go on babe
and um even last minute i
was gonna wear heels and i changed my
mind and wore flats just to be
comfortable
um so it's a lot of like
little things that i just like changed
my mind and i was like you know what
well you know i actually was gonna be
okay with the dress i was gonna wear and
just make the best of it but then you
actually told me you're like you know
what send it
you know
get you know get what you want yeah you
know and like and you're not very
confrontational you don't like a lot of
confrontation and you know that kind of
thing
i also wanted michael to have that
freedom of like
sorry i'm like looking everywhere yeah
just look at the camera
talk to talk to the people they want to
see those pretty guys
well so i just like
i don't even know what i was saying
anymore you just okay but let me let me
let me help you you know rachel's all
nervous about this okay so like the
dress it didn't i okay when you saw the
dre i wish we would have taken a picture
of the dress in the plastic
because now i'm telling you now and i
said this last week in my pockets i
don't know if you heard rachel but when
you show cause she was so nervous about
the dress and she wasn't sure so she was
like i didn't want to see her in the
dress before the wedding but i said let
me let me see it so i went in and saw it
and when she showed it to me in the
plastic
inside my head i was like oh my god what
the hell is that
just honestly i was like but i didn't
want to let you know i felt like that
because babe honestly you look beautiful
in so many things like if i show
somebody from your instagram right now
there's like some nonsense that of
fashion stuff you wear that i don't know
anybody would wear that and you make it
look good so i i had faith that you'd
make it look good but i was nervous that
you weren't going to be happy and all
that you know just so you know
i mean
i knew i know how to just work it so
like that's what you know like it's a
runway you just you get the dress you're
dealt with and then you work it so
that's what i was like gonna do and just
like you know make the best of it but
i you know i i sent him a text he was
like
send it in the morning and i'll have it
done and
um yeah so then we had to like so we had
to uber the dress over to uh the guy
which we didn't we've never done that
before right i don't know if you i
didn't even know you could do that yeah
i was like how do you over address
there's actually a selection in like
uber delivery okay so we ubered the
dress over and then our her good friend
amanda picked the dress up and then
because we were busy at rehearsal
you know when it ended up looking like
that guys just so you could see again
and then and rachel designed that
herself and so babe i just want to tell
you live on the podcast in front of
everybody in front of the world you did
such a fantastic job with this dress it
was
it is so beautiful
uh it just it was just it it was just
spectacular more than any i even could
have imagined
well thank you
and then here's the thing too you know
all right so i said this last week on
the podcast i'm saying in front of
rachel now
there's two times
i think the woman wants you to cry
i'm doing your vows and when she's
walking out
right because you said that to me why
didn't you cry
well like
you told me you weren't even going to
look at me when i walked down the aisle
so
like
when i was walking down i was just like
enjoying being with my dad because like
you know
i wasn't even sure if he was going to be
able to walk me down so like and it was
a long walk too
i was just like taking in every like
second every moment and like now i'm
gonna cry
and
i remember like looking at you down that
aisle and just
being like okay he's just trying not to
cry no i'm i want to tell you right now
cuz i didn't because you didn't listen
to the podcast but i want you to know
something i was worried about the dress
and i was worried about how you were
gonna feel i really was i wasn't sure
how you were gonna feel if you were
gonna would it be this and it looked
so good that i was just amazed i was in
awe i just was like wow you look and i
just it was like i was at a runway show
and just you walking down with your dad
yeah i was just like damn you it looked
so good that i just couldn't even my
emotions was all about how great it
looked you know what i mean just how
great you looked how it all came
together you know what i mean and i was
already emotional too from walking up
with my mom you know what i mean
and i mean did you talk about your suit
as well yeah and my suit was like you
know it was like i didn't know it was
all white i didn't know but that was all
here i don't know what it was gonna look
like either so i was just hoping it
would match my dress oh and it did and
then and then the bouquets perfect what
was the bouquets made out of again um
succulents succulents because rachel
made them yeah so shout out to jordy
jordy sklar um she
she was so talented i know she made some
some great she made them herself it was
so good uh and i had i was so picky and
i um am allergic to flowers so i didn't
want something i didn't want to hold the
flowers
you know and like be allergic
during the best moment of my life so
and it literally was
one of the best moments i know it was
i'm showing a picture of us right now
when we were cutting a cake so like her
mom made that little boutonniere thing
that i had on right there too which was
so nice so that was dope and then um you
know and then like so some other fun
things at the wedding was like rachel's
friends that showed up all her model
friends shout out to them
like you guys don't know that
these girls are so tall
they sure did but they're all tall like
rachel's
rachel's 5 11 6 foot okay
and look how tall the other ones are
they're all they're ginormous it was
like the wnba
you know
that's all their friends and look how
multi-ethnic too you know what i mean so
and then it was like all these beautiful
models and then you know the ugly ass
comics that were there with their
girlfriends or people that came by
themselves
but it you know but it was good so you
excited about cancun babe but let's talk
about the honeymoon because we're
leaving so because i'm gonna i'm gonna
get you off i just told you to
just plan it
i hate traveling so this is like
a big
what a is it five hour flight or
something like that yeah it's like for
our flight but we're flying first class
i i i got the good stuff for us okay
thank you but
i mean hopefully i don't
like throw up on the way there yeah me
too me too and um i'm just hoping for
the best and i hope the weather is great
and
i mean
i'm sure it's gonna be an amazing time
and something that we'll never forget
yes i hope so too babe and i'm glad you
came on everybody
oh and thank you for the super chat so
we got a bunch of super chats too babe
which is like people are like sending
little little tips and stuff like that
so um i appreciate you guys and
everybody say
goodbye to
mrs griffin because she still has some
packing to do because i notice that the
suitcase isn't you know
well you
interrupted my packing yeah because she
actually wasn't wearing this outfit like
10 minutes ago and all of a sudden
hopefully it looks good on camera you
look great babe i i i'm using this
little i'm gonna get a better camera
from when i do this more often but uh
you still can like have you come on more
often but anyways guys say goodbye to
mrs griffin thank you rachel thank you
for coming on love you babe love you bye
bye
turn the mic off for me
okay hand it to me thank you all right
guys yeah there was uh
you know riffing with mrs griffin huh
she's looking good
uh yeah get your soda
um so anyways yeah
um yeah the wedding was
you know it's really good i'm gonna look
at this i mean i just want to look at
this dress again because like i said you
guys don't even understand
you know
oh that's a go that's a good one right
there this is oh this is one of the
fittings yeah oh so this is
like there's two different sleeves oh
right right right yeah oh i see what
you're saying oh okay let's look at this
right now
yeah so okay so there it is right this
is like in the making process that's
michael castello right there right yeah
so that's the big designer right there
michael costello if anybody's interested
in that and like so she was like doing
this like really in this really sexy
dress i didn't know it was going to be
so sexy it was really nice
uh and rachel knows i love her belly
button so she was trying to get the
belly button in there
okay baby if you're gonna talk you have
to like
babe you know
anyways
it was like it was very beautiful she
did she really she really did a great
job
in the process of making this dress
yeah so this was like the walk that she
was doing you can see this on rachel's
instagram
okay so then this is how it looked at
first and you know so there was no
rhinestones on it yet and it was just
like yeah there was a different belt
different sleeves and all this kind of
stuff and this is like her friends that
went
like look at look at how little he is in
comparison to all these
ginormous women
even her mom is tall you know what i
mean but anyways shout out to them um
but anyways thanks babe
um all right guys
so yeah we're off to cancun and it's
gonna be a fun time but i said i needed
to get my podcast in before i left you
know because i i'm not gonna do it
tomorrow you know what i mean
so you know it is what it is but
actually let's take some time right now
and uh pay some bills uh so once again
shout out to mrs griffin thanks for
coming on the podcast and uh let's go
back to
uh shout out to the people that
are sponsoring the podcast now like five
cbd
love five cbd guys i'm not a weed smoker
i'm not i'm just not i never have been i
don't drink alcohol or nothing like that
but you know i you know i just like i
was like you know what
i've tried a few times where i've tried
some cbd and i was like ooh and you have
to have a little to me you have to have
a little bit of something in in the cbd
to really unlock it and make it good
but five cvd was founded by some hemp
enthusiasts to unlock the power of full
spectrum cbd you don't get buzzed
you know sometimes people like they
don't like to have that high feeling
five cbd is perfect it's like the
perfect amount if you just want to feel
feel
chill and you really feel that because i
don't like that feeling of not knowing
what's going on and this stuff is
perfect they ship legally to all 50
states five cbd for everyone life's
moved fast life moves fast and sometimes
you need to remind yourself to just kick
back and relax
five cbd has designed
high quality affordable and fun full
spectrum products that help you slow
things down
um like i say man i really enjoy it i
take it at night right before i go to
bed you know
not every day but just occasionally you
know and it's it's good i highly
recommend it you know i never thought
i'd be somebody that would be
recommending something like this it's
not even just because of the ad i legit
tried it and i was like ooh like this a
lot so if you're not looking to get all
super high and have that kind of feeling
but if you just want to have a chill
mellow right in the zone five cbd i
highly recommend it uh getting
uh five cbd list uh five cbd
uh like i say is a great product and i
really appreciate them for being a
sponsor of the podcast so riffing with
griffin listeners get 30 off and free
shipping on their first order of five
cbd
go to 5cbd.com griffin and enter code
griffin at checkout for 30 off and free
shipping on your first order that's five
f
f i v e spell it out 5cbd.com
griffin and enter code griffin at
checkout for 30 off and free shipping on
your first order
all right let's now talk about upstart
love upstart um
you know it can be hard to see the light
at the end of the tunnel when it comes
to your finances like high interest rate
debt
let's talk about it you know what that
is it's like when you have a credit card
it's got 25 interest sometimes people
get discredit stuff and they think they
they think they got oh i got 3 000 worth
of credit or whatever how much it is but
you don't realize that high interest
rate is gonna put you under all right
say goodbye to high interest credit card
debt it's one of the first steps towards
financial independence but the interest
month to month
can feel like a never-ending hamster
wheel that's what i'm talking about
that's where upstart comes in all right
upstart powered personal loans can help
you pay down high interest rate all
online with simple and easy to
understand payment terms upstart has
helped up to 1.8 million customers on
their path to financial freedom and
upstart they don't just go off your
credit score all right they go off a lot
of factors credit score income
employment and other information
provided in your loan application to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
you can check your rate in minutes for
loans between 1 000 to 50 000 without
impacting your credit score and that's
super important so don't wait and check
your rate today at upstart.com
griffin that's upstart.com
griffin to check your rate today don't
forget to use our url to let them know
we sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application
go to
upstart.com slash griffin
all right guys we paid the bills can you
pay my bills pay my towel i'm on bells
um all right let's go into like okay
let's i want to go into now the the some
stuff i wanted to talk about uh in this
week's episode let's go for some nba
talk now
all right nba talk so the finals are
over uh and
golden state one
uh oh man i'm hiding steph curry but
let's just show them the man himself
four-time champ steph curry
so um i told you when i was been talking
about the nba up to this point that
there were a lot of great story lines in
the nba this year in this playoffs
especially
and
it turned out that one of the best story
lines was golden state warriors winning
this championship i think it's one of
their i think it's the most significant
of their championships of all four of
them i think this one was the one that
means the most to me
uh that's why it was an important
championship that's why this run was so
this improbable run to get back to the
championship was so great for golden
state and shout out to them i hate
golden state i'm a clippers fan but i
can appreciate what they've done uh it
it was really it was really special this
was a special run i mean you know if
you're a hater you go back to the first
championship
you know lebron takes him to six games
without kevin without kevin love without
kyrie irving there isn't a person alive
even if you're a golden state fan you
know the cleveland cavaliers we're gonna
beat them okay
it's just
it's just that's just a fact okay that's
just but we'll never know they won they
won the championship then the next year
they actually lose they're up 3-1 they
choke it away and they lose the
championship then the year after that
they get kevin durant so
it's hard to like have any sort of
respect for those championships because
it was just like who could beat them
you know they went to the championship
three years in a row klay thompson gets
hurt in the third one kevin durant gets
hurt and
toronto wins that's why i don't i have
zero respect for that toronto
championship but it is what it is they
survived they stayed healthy they won so
maybe i have one percent respect so it's
like and then you got kevin durant
deciding because he was getting so much
slack
it's like damn i'm never gonna get the
respect i deserve if i stay with golden
state so let me move on and try to do my
own thing and so now with the injuries
to golden state what happened to them
they fell off they had the worst record
in the league
last year the last two years were
terrible they didn't even make the
playoffs and so for them to revamp
retool get klay thompson back he isn't
even really 100 but he's good wiseman
got hurt and he wasn't even there but
the way wiggins stepped up the way
jordan poole stepped up looney and these
guys they showed that the system the
culture of golden state
is a championship culture and they can
put other pieces in to replace an
all-time talent like kevin durant and
win the championship and not only did
they do that not only did they prove
that it's golden state that's the
championships not the people that play
what i'm mean to say is yeah thanks for
coming and winning the championship
kevin durant but they didn't win because
of you they they won
with you they won because of what golden
state does
and
it you you got it you can't hate on them
you just really can't they got
that cultured how they play
how they play their brand of basketball
it literally brings the best out of
everyone on the court
uh that just you know that
wiggins was like
off in obscurity
and then he was a number one pick that
just fell off and now
he was the second best player on the
court
during those during many of the finals
games
so
they people just shined in that system
and so when you take someone like kevin
durant who is an all-time great
and you put that kind of person in that
system he's gonna flourish but he did he
hasn't flourished
outside of golden state
they lost to lebron in okc they choked
against golden state then he went to you
know he got injured he came back he's
with the nets they didn't beat the bucks
and then now they got swept by boston so
go to state's winning this one right now
hopefully next year
it'd be great to see the nets versus
what's the final four we want to see
next year the final four we want to see
next year is boston nets
maybe
maybe antetokounmpo comes back too but i
really like boston they choked by the
way i will get to boston but
i want to see the lakers golden state
you know that you know hopefully lebron
came one last run for lebron right
because if if it is lakers golden state
in the western finals which is unlikely
but you never know you know with lebron
you never know what he could do that
would be great because then it's like he
has four steph has four who could go get
to fifth
and then boston i'd like to see the
maturation of that team really fulfill
their destiny because they've been to
the west the eastern finals three times
and now they got to the finals and they
just they gave that away they choked i
thought they were the bigger stronger
faster more talented team but they just
they didn't have it up here they didn't
have it up there and golden state won uh
tatum he's totally 24 years old but he
did not show up and you know
that that's a learning curve for him and
we'll see if he can really
like take it over the top and be an mvp
be the best player in the league because
that's what it's going to take to win
the championship and then also look man
shout out to steph curry right like
steph curry
he got the the finals mvp and he he
needed that he could say he didn't want
it but he did he needed it
he was the best player throughout the
whole finals
he was he averaged 30 something points
and he they won because of him i heard
another talk show host say this and so
i'm just you know i'm stealing this but
i'm saying it i'm not like i'm coming up
with this on my own but when i heard it
i was like marcellus wiley on uh speak
for yourself on fox i love that dude i
love that show check out speak for
yourself i love the conversations they
have with emmanuel acho and him but
said something great that steph curry
had his kobe moment and i thought about
that and what he meant by that is
the lakers won three championships
but when you remember those
championships you always think of shaq
super dominant three finals mvps
then they had a falling out
kobe was like get me out of here
jerry bust uh decided we're gonna keep
kobe we're gonna trade shaq
and then kobe went on to win two more
championships and he was the driving
force he was the reason why they won and
that's what he wanted he wanted to be he
wanted his respect like i'm an all-time
great
and so kobe did that he won his two
championships and so then
you know that's what steph curry did
with this championship he was like okay
i didn't win the finals mvp we had kevin
durant you know we we lost to lebron uh
we didn't win we won when kev kyrie and
kevin love wasn't playing i need to be
the one you know and he was he was the
one so kudos to steph curry and the
golden state warriors and now it's like
they're right there like why won't they
be back in the again like they are a
strong team and they got people coming
back they're young they're you know they
have some i'm saying they're not young
but they have young players their core
is old but they got young players who
fit right in so i'm looking forward to
see what's going to happen with the
golden state warriors
in the west because the western
conference is loaded
you hear what i'm saying loaded
denver is going to be better because
they're going to have jamal murray's
coming back and the other dude that was
injured so they're gonna be fully loaded
luca and dallas
maybe they'll make a trade to get one
other player to help that guy but look
what they did man
they're gonna be loaded uh what are you
what are you talking about minnesota is
a young team that's looking good you got
the lakers can they get their stuff
together and my clippers my clippers are
going to be back next year son you got
kawhi leonard paul george fully healthy
and ready to go they got the most
talented roster i can't wait to see what
they're gonna do and that's not to
mention memphis you know if john moran
didn't get hurt golden state might not
have even gotten past them this year so
they're gonna be good the western
conference is going to be stacked next
year but so is the east
onto the compost
buck's gonna be good with uh with chris
milton coming back he was injured so
they were the champs last year they're
gonna be good the sixers they're looking
like they're gonna be good you know
hopefully kev uh james harding can get
his [ __ ] together we'll see what's going
on there you gotta think the nets are
gonna be good right the bulls look good
i mean there's a lot of teams like i
think this the nba is in a really great
place so we will see where
that's gonna go so
it's great and i see somebody in chat
talking about steve kerr yes shout out
to steve kerr nine time champion y'all
nine time champion
five as a player
three with the bulls two with san
antonio four as a coach hall of fame
that guy's just everything about what he
does for the culture of golden state is
great so you know i can't wait for the
nba next year kudos to that so it's
gonna be real good so looking forward to
that
yeah
all right um what else it's gonna be a
short episode or you know not as long as
normal because i just needed to get this
episode out
um because
i like to do an episode every week and i
needed to get it done before i went on
my honeymoon so old news but i never got
to talk about it guys
let's get into
the johnny depp amber heard
verdict trial and everything that
happened
uh with that
um
so
i have a lot of thoughts about this and
you know it is it is what it is uh you
know
i don't know like what your thoughts are
out there uh i i want to be respectful
to like you know
just because i'm talking about this this
isn't i just want to say this this is
just about this trial
just because i feel whatever i feel
about this trial and my thoughts about
what happened between these two people
it is not you know i'm not doesn't mean
that there's some blanket statement or
generalization for all of these types of
cases okay let me just say that right
now all right
first of all
let me put my thoughts out right away
about what i feel
i i believe johnny depp okay
and i believe johnny depp for a lot of
reasons um but the main reason why i
believe johnny depp
is
he
he had to
say in court
part of his defense was
i'm a drug addict i'm an alcoholic i'm a
flawed human being that was part of his
defense like he had to admit that in
open court
but i'm not a rapist or an abuser
like that bothered him so much
that he had to fight
for his that part of his honor like
crazy think about to have to admit all
these other things just to be like yeah
i'm an alcoholic but i don't rape people
i'm with him on that
here's the thing though dudes out there
gentlemen guys watching
stop acting like we won the super bowl
cause we didn't all right like i got
i've gotten hit up like one for the boys
we didn't win [ __ ] a rich guy won
i mean the justice system unfortunately
is set up for people with money can get
the most out of the justice system not
all of us can
like
there are many people who have been
accused of things
that they want to fight it but they just
don't got the money to fight it like
this dude got money he's been fighting
this for six years he got six years of
fighting money we all don't have that so
if you know someone out there and
there's been people i have people i know
that are being accused of things that
i'm telling you they wanna they would
would have wanted to fight but like it's
a losing battle with the way the court
system is set up the way the justice
system is set up there's no justice for
the victims that don't have money and
there's no justice for people for people
that are innocent that don't have money
or who want to fight i mean it's really
it really sucks you know but in this
case we have two rich people going at
each other so from the beginning of this
trial
it was like these two people belong
together all the information that came
out about them
in court was just like uh it was yucky
you know what i mean
didn't want to see it
i i i thought it was shameful the way
they were going at each other you know
her [ __ ] in his bed and the cutting
off the finger and all you know
how he would how he was with his
daughter and and then how she was with
him and then the fake acting in court
and just like it was just like my god
why are we watching this these two
people deserve each other you know what
i mean
you know what i mean it's like
what
you know so
so then for them to like go through this
you know it was it was just a god
it was just like
it was terrible to me to watch to
witness you know
and
here's the thing that i think that
happened
and i've talked about this before in
terms of
like the woke
sort of super sensitive uber people who
think they're so enlightened
y'all are not enlightened as you think
you are because you are so easily
weaponized
that's why we have to take a pause man
we got to take a pause when things come
out so we can get some facts
get some due process
find out what's going on like how many
imagine look what happened when they put
these two in court we found out a lot
and we were able to be like oh i don't
believe this person and they both won
something by the way because he lied on
her too she won also
so anyway
the the woke are so easily weaponized
all it takes is somebody to be like
this happened just an allegation and
because of an allegation
there's a segment of society that will
just believe it no evidence
no trial no investigation just somebody
said and then it's believed
that is dangerous don't you see that
it's dangerous because someone like
amber heard who is smart
and spiteful
obviously she was like i know how to get
this fool back i know what to do i'm
gonna do this and and i know everyone's
gonna believe me and the washington post
co-signed it and then what happened he
lost his money his job he you know all
the things that happened he was shunned
and shamed in society because of what
she said
you know what
he got his due his time in court he
proved that that was a lie
and and it's like if we would have just
taken a beat
so many people lost the media lost for
the simple fact that hey washington post
why don't you do some investigating on
this you just co-signed this thing
and ruin this guy's reputation with no
was there any investigation who even
knows boom that's done
so they lose
and then that's why i say guys stop
thinking we won something because we
didn't because what's the sad part about
this is women lose big time in this so
let's say
if you're a woman watching this right
now you're super mad at me because you
believed amber heard and i respect that
if you believe amber heard was telling
the truth that johnny depp is just a
abuser and a rapist okay you believe
that i understand then you lose that's
when women lose in that that believe
that because a rich white guy got away
with it right
or
what i believe she weaponized the metoo
movement against him because she knew
there would be no real investigating and
you could just say this about someone
and then um
the the mob the mob will take him down
you lose because now
all of those real victims out there all
of those people who are really going
through something that want to speak out
they got put they they take they get a
strike because of cause
because of what she did weaponizing it
like this so you know it is what it is
you know what i mean um so it's just
it's
the whole thing like i say the whole
thing sucks but
you know i feel like there i feel like
they they they deserve each other like i
wouldn't be surprised if they made a
reality show you know what i mean like
if i was like e or bravo
mtv any of these kind of places i would
go right to them and be like yo you guys
want to do a reality show we'll pay you
50 million dollars each and just can we
just film you guys trying to work it out
man that would be the best show on tv
who would not want to watch like johnny
depp because he's like bat [ __ ] man
you know just the way he is you know you
know what i mean he
it's like life imitating art art
imitating life you know what i mean it's
so crazy and then the way she was i was
like god damn artists are funky they got
there's something going on there's some
funky feelings going on there man so i
would love to see
that
okay i would love to see that so maybe
maybe we can make it happen
it'll be better than some of these
stupid you know housewives shows or all
this other drama that you see on tv that
would be like a super dramatic show that
i would love to watch so maybe we should
put that out in the universe you know
what i mean so
we'll see what happens you know we'll
we'll see what happens in their future
but just in closing like you know it's
like i just
i just want everybody out there like
take a pause man
just because a news organization even
like the washington post or the la times
or the new york post or new york times
or whatever
paper just because they write an article
about someone
it doesn't mean that it's true
there's a lot of factors and nuance and
stuff that we don't are not privy to
that unfortunately not everybody that is
talked about has the resources to use
the justice system to their benefit to
fight it or to just get their day in
court to be like yo that you that's not
what happened because it doesn't matter
because the mob
you
people watching social media
you know they don't care
if somebody calls you something then
that's it you're that
forever
unfortunately and it's sad it's
assassinated affairs but
hopefully
hopefully this gate gave some people
pause i mean it's like damn and then
closing also who lost to me is like the
people that just made this choice to
just fire him
you know like they like they they just
cow towed to like public pressure
the the optics of it like just what are
the optic the optics are well all these
people say he did this thing bad so we
got to get rid of him
man that sucks you know what i mean it
sucks
i wish that he would just not get i wish
he would tell her keep your money that'd
be so funny if he was like i just wanted
that i just wanted them to say i didn't
do this and you were lying so keep your
money that'd be dope but whatever it is
what it is
and i see people talking [ __ ] you know i
don't understand why people are here
like you know people talk so much [ __ ]
dude
this is my podcast i do what i want you
know this is how i am guys i'm working
on it you know
you know i wish i was funnier on the
podcast but it is what it is
this is how i am man i get deep about
stuff this is why you watch me for all
you regulars thanks for being here for
other people who like are talking [ __ ]
they're still like oh
uh
you know what i mean like i don't wait i
don't know what wait i see i see an
[ __ ] in the uh chat so let me just
you know get rid of them bye
[Laughter]
it's people like that man i just i don't
there's so many there's so many
[ __ ] in the world man i don't know
what you know
this is me man this is what i do you
know i guess here here's something
here's something that i'll i'll end with
i'm driving with rachel we're going to
uh
going to like freaking malibu right
and
right in the car
right and
one of these dumb big stupid dumb
motorcycles pulls up beside us
with speakers and the freaking music is
blaring
like
who are you
i don't even like when a car
i don't even like when a car is playing
loud music because i'm like yo put your
windows down nobody want to hear your
dumb ass music but when you want a bike
first of all the bike is so big
get a car
okay just get a car
the bike bike is big as a freaking prius
like what are you doing and then you got
speakers on it blasting out
with a helmet on wear some damn
headphones i don't even
i do not understand that people
people that ride motorcycles and play
loud music amplify music
eat it suck it
all right straight up suck it
all right guys i gotta finish packing
myself get my stuff together so we can
get out of here and get on our honeymoon
super excited about that
i know i know sometimes i am an old man
but guys thank you for being here i
wanted to get the episode out and i
appreciate you guys all your support
even you haters i still appreciate you
make sure you subscribe to the podcast
subscribe and all that stuff i'm working
on it if you notice on my social media
shout out to kristen espinoza she's my
new producer you know she's been helping
me like really promote the podcast i
feel like i'm getting the numbers are
going a little better so i appreciate
that i'm also on twitch won't be on
twitch for a whole week because i'm
going to be uh on my honeymoon and i am
going to be doing some once i get back
from the honeymoon i'm going to be like
really centering on some more patreon
content so i appreciate that i'm
actually
gonna
going
you if you go on the picture i'm gonna
be taking pictures from the honeymoon
and all that's gonna be on patreon first
so i appreciate you guys
shout out to mrs griffin
for coming on the podcast
love her
love you guys and
i'll see you next week and it'll just
maybe something fun and exciting will
happen on the honeymoon and i'll talk
about that you know but i appreciate you
guys for being here
and as always see you next
week
[Music]
[Music]
your feet
[Music]
[Music]
you